hey youtubers it's Charlie this is gonna
be my agents of shield episode 20 video
pretty much the Captain America Civil
War crossover the official crossover
azula's minor point two crossover when
they're discussing stuff about Hydra but
they were talking about stuff that was
happening during the Civil War movie so
there will be minor Civil War spoilers
in this it was all about the sokovia
accords registering Inhumans so the
direction the TV show took with it was a
little more comic book Civil War with
the superhero Registration Act than the
movie which is really about putting the
Avengers under government control or
government oversight so when Talbot had
that scene with Coulson at the beginning
of the episode the spies like us episode
with the elevator down to the base he
was talking about bringing shield back
into the light under government control
the same way the Avengers are now they
paid off the setup with another nice
comic book reference to secret warriors
which like I've said this season is a
comic book arc but it's also the name of
a team in the comics just a team of
Inhumans that they have on the TV show
but there was also a little ghostwriter
and the only thing I really didn't like
about this week's episode was really
that they killed their third act to get
to that lash reveal they really could
have spent that along the whole MacGyver
scene just absolutely killed the episode
but it is fun to see them twist the idea
of the Terrigen bomb in a really nasty
way you know those monster men Inhumans
that hive is trying to create so instead
of the normal top 5 let's just turn this
into an Easter Egg Civil War video just
because that was mostly what was going
on in the episode you probably spotted
the newscast that was the most direct
Civil War crossover when they're talking
about Tony Stark the Avengers the
sokovia accords then Coulson looks at
the newspaper sees Peggy Carter's o
bitchu Arry
and then Talbot walks in and they have
this scene that's very much like The
Incredible Hulk post-credit scene with
Tony Stark and Thunderbolt Ross that
scene was mostly about iron man telling
Thunderbolt Ross that he was putting the
Avengers together the monster man
primitive Inhumans that hive is creating
are kind of like what he does in the
comics on the TV show he has those small
nanite parasites that just infect
people's brains in the comics they look
more like facehuggers to just attach to
people's faces but it amounts to the
same thing he gains a level of control
over them his plan to detonate the virus
in the atmosphere is a lot like a
perverted version of black bolts
terrigen bomb that was during the
infinity arc which is actually a long
time ago like it was way before Secret
Wars but that was the event in the
comics that they used to surface the
Kamala Khan Miss Marvel
she got her powers when she went through
the Terrigen mist Hellfire making a nice
ghostwriter references he whips his
chain of fire the way they visually
animated this to is also a lot like the
way they animate the Ghost Rider chain
in the movies so I'm not really sure who
holds the rights to that right now they
may not have reverted back to Marvel
because I think if they could they would
think about doing like a Ghost Rider
Netflix series but that requires a lot
of CG so it's a little bit harder to do
than dared up on some of the other
series totally dug the lash Hulk smash
third act reveal that was what they were
building to in the episode like the
doors open and it's lash and it's like
surprise the problem that kind of
spoiled it is they took way too long to
get there I feel like they should have
sped through a lot of that MacGyver
stuff or just completely found a way
around it and spent way more time during
that lash action scene where he just
mows down all of hives people the kind
of a bummer that they killed them I
guess they want to give the hive kill to
someone else but the real WTF is that we
find out that Mac now has yo-yos cross
because they said they're gonna be
shooting a warhead into space someone's
gonna have to go into space to try and
stop it that's probably what's happening
in this scene right here so let me know
in the comments do you think that
they're actually going to kill off Mac
this season or is there gonna be some
Joss Whedon style deus ex machina save
in the last episode where someone will
save mac from space because they kind of
did the same thing on arrow this season
where they were showing a character in a
grave we didn't know who it was all
season but they kept going back to this
grave scene someone's gonna die then
after we found out who it was they're
like oh yeah they're definitely not
coming back but this dead character in
space could be like a WTF fake-out where
you think they're dead but then you move
forward a couple moments in that episode
in someone ends up saving them Maxo
decent character most of his best scenes
this season have been with yo-yos
character this was episode 20 there are
two more episodes left in the season I'm
probably gonna wait till the start of
next season before I decide if I keep
doing agents of shield videos they've
been getting better and now that they're
not really doing it in humans movie they
might have opportunities for the TV show
to do certain inhuman characters like
the royal family but creatively I just I
feel like the show isn't quite where it
needs to be so it's not quite as fun
spending hours and hours making videos
for it is I think it could be so we'll
see there's just been so much more movie
stuff happening that I've been trying to
clear room in my schedule so it might
ended
being some of the TV shows that people
don't care as much about next season so
they can do more movie videos but
nothing's set in stone yet the one TV
show that I am really excited for this
summer that actually looks pretty cool
is Voltron Netflix is dropping a new
Voltron series all at the same time in
June it's being animated by the same
studio that animated Legend of Korra so
it looks beautiful what I'm gonna do is
a trailer video for that tomorrow just
to kind of give everybody a preview and
do like a good Voltron history video
Voltron was very precious to my
childhood so look out for that tomorrow
while you guys wait for my next video to
post you can click here for my Captain
America Civil War Easter eggs and you
can click here for my breakdown of the
post-credits scenes thank you so much
for watching everybody let's high five
I'll see you guys tonight
you